Gaga's yummy, new diet keeps her healthy on the road.
Hi, I'm Nicole Paggi for E! News Now.
Lady G has one of the most grueling schedules of any performer.
Just a few months ago, the singer fainted on stage during one of her shows.
Now we're learning about her new secret weapon for staying strong while on tour.
Pop's most Twitterrific idol is saying yes to fresh food.
The popular singer is on a health kick since passing out at a concert in New Zealand back in March.
Gaga's choreographer tells People.com,...
"The singer has added tofu, turkey slices, hummus, and coconut water to her diet."
But don't feel too bad for Lady G.
She still has an occasional splurge before hitting the stage.
"We'll have a toast or two with a little white wine." the source says.
It's a good bet all her devoted Little Monsters will be following her healthy lifestyle very soon.
Thanks for watching.
Stay up-to-date on your favorite celebs all day long at E! Online and be sure to follow us on Twitter.
Username: enewsnow, your link to the hottest entertainment videos.